[Music]
welcome everybody to next 22. today we
are going to help you understand how to
take advantage of the latest product
Innovations we have done around data
integration and bigquery with our data
accelerated content uh with codex
framework
um and my name is chaitanya padimokala
I'm head of products for data
integration at Google cloud data
analytics group and I'm joined with my
friend and colleague Alison hetrick
she's the director of solutions cortex
framework at Google Cloud
today we're going to touch upon a few
things one is the primary thing is you
know what is on top of mind for data
driven organizations and Enterprises
what are the challenges that these
data-driven organizations are facing on
a daily basis
what are the key principles that drive
you to build a modern data platform and
how can you actually build this with
Google Cloud Technologies then you know
you'll be joined with by my friend
Alison who's going to talk about not
just building the data platform but how
can you actually use our solution
accelerators
um based on cortex framework for sap and
Beyond to get more additional insights
and then you know you will also find
some you know valuable links where you
can find more information
so with that let me actually talk about
what is on top of mind for you know data
driven organizations other Enterprises
the biggest challenge you know one of
the customers are facing and all these
organizations are facing today is
the amount of data that is being thrown
at the Enterprises you know the data
growth is exponential the data is also
coming in a lot of different formats
there is unstructured data that is
coming into the Enterprises uh
structured data data in real time data
in batch
the other thing you know that we also
see is almost 75 percent of the
organizations are struggling and they
want to operationalize the AIML but
there are more processing Frameworks
that are available it's not just SQL
anymore and you know sometimes you
actually have to process the data in
real time you need streaming analytics
you need latest and greatest AI ml
mechanisms to actually process your data
I need to be able to create effective
data products uh we also see that about
three-fourths of the data leaders are
also asking for real-time access of data
the looking at the historical data and
making decisions is important but it is
also important to preempt looking at the
real-time data and just any key business
decisions on a daily basis is becoming
imperative to these data leaders so even
though we have all these challenges we
have seen that most of the companies are
unable to realize any measurable value
of the data being it's purely because
obviously data is huge data requires
more than SQL to process houses and data
is reaching everyone and this is causing
a lot of silos in an organization the
customers and organizations require more
and more capacity there is security risk
and this actually is also you know has
an impact on top and bottom line of the
companies increasing the costs call
they're always trying to you know plan
the capacity and you know it is also
affecting the SLS in the organizations
so we at Google you know we think that
you know there are foundational
principles in actually in a modern data
platform right when we look at you know
Google we have 10x thinking we think
about moonshots what are the next big
things that we need to solve that need
to be solved and when we think about the
10x thinking we want to help Empower
data driven organizations and bring that
thinking to them and the way we do it is
through bringing data-driven Innovation
that actually with a limitless data
Cloud so when you actually have a cloud
platform that can actually deal with
Limitless data and run and process the
data at scale with Limitless workloads
and can actually enable every single
user in the organization and Beyond the
organization to get access to the data
and the data right data reaches the
right people in a secure and governed
fashion then it is possible that you can
have true Limitless Innovation this is
something that we want to actually bring
to our customers so that they can
benefit from The Innovation that we have
done so if you look at Google data Cloud
we actually build this data Cloud to
solve for every single user starting
from your you know data producers data
Engineers ml Engineers data scientists
and the data consumers and people are
actually and data product managers and
you know we have mechanisms to bring in
the data collect the data store the data
in a purpose-built fashion analyze the
data on our bigquery platform and then
not just analysis of the data but to be
able to find new insights that you can
actually help activate these insights in
your Downstream application so that
you're making Better Business decisions
and all of these data Cloud platform is
built on our Google Cloud infrastructure
with the latest and greatest security
mechanisms encryption mechanisms we
actually make a lot of the things that
were in the thoughts of our customers
before like high availability and you
know disaster recovery we make it an
afterthought with our platform and we
not only have this data Cloud on Google
Cloud that works on with Google Cloud
infrastructure but we also have enabled
so that our partners can work with the
data Cloud we actually sponsor a lot of
these open source Technologies and we
also allow the capabilities to actually
cut across to other third-party clouds
because we know that you know customers
want to Leverage The some of these
capabilities on other clouds
um and the way we do it is because we
have purpose-built services for each
each one of the use cases that we want
to solve like for Enterprise data
integration we have data Fusion or if
you want to do serverless spark loads uh
you know spark workloads to process data
we have services for those so we have a
lot of different services for you know
all the personas but because they are
built on the same fabric and they are
using the same governance and data
fabric we make it easy so that the
services work seamlessly with each other
and this is only have you know we are
able to make this happen because
bigqueries that are hard of innovation
because bigquery grew out of our own
necessity to innovate to build a better
storage mechanism and we use it uses
Colossus as a storage mechanism we have
a unique way of ensuring that there is
always Computing capacity and we use our
internal Computing infrastructure and
cluster management system called porg we
also have Dremel which is our query
mechanism that is built on bigquery and
that is how we are doing it and we also
have cloud data Fusion that actually
helps you bring in all these Enterprise
data from sap and Beyond other
applications in a comprehensive no code
fashion so that you know you can lower
the total cost of ownership with that
let me hand over to my uh friend and
colleague Alison who's going to talk
about you know I've talked about the
technology stack but it only solves one
piece of the puzzle but how with cortex
framework
you can actually take full advantage of
Technology stack and built on top of it
to actually solve real world problems
over to you Allison
thank you so much chai
let's now take a look at some of the
solution accelerators and content for
Enterprise data and Beyond and some of
the work that we're doing in this space
to help you accelerate your journey to
the data cloud
insights across the operation today have
never been more complex there's a
variety of different data sets that you
contend with as you look at the notion
of being able to connect and provide
insights in support of your business or
your business operations
so the question for many is how can we
help you get connected insights faster
one of the ways we're doing this is by
introducing cortex framework
there are three main areas of Cortex
framework that are focused around
accelerating your journey in data
analytics and to the data cloud
the first focus is on providing
connectors that are endorsed
Google connectors partner connectors and
those that we've been able to validate
and vet that work very well with our
templates and content
the second area focuses around the
ability for you to accelerate your
journey to the data cloud and providing
templates and content and examples to
help get you started and to make that
Journey go a whole lot more cost
effective and faster
the last area of value and focus is
around how to tie all of the templates
and content together to develop
Innovative use cases and solutions and
to have those Solutions be delivered not
only through Google but with those of
our partners as well
so what's inside cortex framework what
are some of the key elements
the first area focuses around the
connectivity and the connectors the
ability to manage and integrate your
data pipelines across variety of
different data sources and to do so in
an endorsed way
the second focuses around providing
reference architectures blueprints that
not only help you to understand how to
apply our data Cloud platform tools and
Technologies but giving you that
strategy that approach based on best
practices the recipe on how you can
accelerate and deliver on Solutions
utilizing Google platform Technologies
and tools
the third area focuses on how to help
you deploy and take advantage of
delivering analytics utilizing Google
bigquery and our major platform
capabilities with bigquery
and last but not least tying that
together with sample machine learning
models examples and content with our Ai
and ml templates
as we look at cortex framework starting
with connectivity with cloud data Fusion
there's the ability to take advantage of
accessing a variety of different
connectors to a number of different data
sets and data sources whether those data
sets be from Google third-party iot and
streaming or even Enterprise
applications such as sap and other
Enterprise data sources cloud data
Fusion provides a variety of connectors
and content that can help you to connect
and access and provide data into Google
bigquery
and to provide you with a comprehensive
approach to do so
as we then take a look at what's in
cortex Foundation at the very center is
a set of pre-delivered models and
content that not only help you process
the data coming in from the raw but also
applying some of these specific change
data capture processing units of measure
processing as well as additional types
of enrichment that may be required to
have true accurate and consistent data
coming from Enterprise data sets and
data sources particularly with
environments such as sap
to the right of the data Foundation we
are also providing best practices-based
examples with AI and ml templates and
content for more common use cases around
a variety of line of business and
industry focused areas
to the left of the data Foundation we're
providing you with the ability to have
application layer templates that can
allow you to readily and easily share
data as microservices and expose your
data out through a pub sub or other
applications that are interested in
accessing the data so whether that data
is developed with our data Foundation
content or models or even yours cortex
is providing a complete Foundation of
content to help you accelerate in this
journey
but we're not only providing access from
a data perspective and some of these
examples we're also remembering the end
user and providing ready to run content
with our looker blocks and templates for
common types of operational analytics
use cases and scenarios
let's take a closer look at some of the
templates and content that we're making
available
first and foremost we have focused on
sap as one of our initial scope and
focus areas for our data models it's not
the only scope and focus for us but it's
an important one because for many
Enterprises integrating data to and from
sap environments and delivering on
comprehensive data models that can help
support your analytics journey is top of
mind and is incredibly important to get
right we're taking the guesswork out of
the integration and the content and the
templates we're providing
what we're also doing is we're providing
flexibility with the templates we're
delivering is part of Cortex framework
to allow you to take your content
readily and easily
share it with external applications and
to make that easily available to other
systems so depending on where your
journey takes you with your data
analytics and the specific insights that
you're looking to connect cortex can
help you accelerate and get there faster
let's now take a closer look at some of
the examples that we can provide in
support of our data Foundation
specifically for sap whether it is
analytics focusing on finance or sales
and distribution to readily and easily
provide you with the data models the
looker blocks and templates to get you
started answering questions such as Day
sales outstanding and finance for
example where are their overdue
receivables or in sales and distribution
is that order on time or in full
all of those types of operational
analytics questions can readily and
easily be answered with our content that
we're making available to you today
in addition to operational and analytics
scenarios we're also focusing around key
use cases demand sensing is a great
example of this the ability to tie in
retail sales data along with weather
data revenue and sales and Order data
can allow you to rapidly and easily
understand if there are signals that may
influence your latest demand forecast
for a product
all of this information helps you to
start to connect insights and to start
to apply the data signals into your
business processes
cortex framework providing these
examples can help you get started and so
while we're delivering a lot of content
around Enterprise data sets and data
sources such as sap cortex can also
readily and easily give you standard
content and data models for weather
holiday and calendar data and other
types of data sets and data signals
so it's a great way to get started and
to Fast Track your data and analytics
Journey
as we think about the value and the key
capabilities with cortex you can focus
on reducing your cost time and risk with
your overall deployment by taking
advantage of not only our connectors to
data Fusion our bigquery data cloud and
data platform capabilities but also
reducing the overall planning and design
efforts around those implementations
cortex is able to give you those
blueprints to help you get started
we're also providing real deployment
content and templates that you can
extend expand and make your own and take
full advantage of these templates even
with your custom developed content that
you are developing in Google bigquery
and last but not least cortex provides
that foundation and framework that not
only helps Google deliver Solutions into
Market faster for our customers but for
you the ability to deliver solutions to
your business a whole lot faster and
more efficiently and effectively
and having our partners as well as
Solutions being developed through cortex
framework provides you with a
standardized approach to get insights
faster and to be able to connect data
more easily
with that that concludes today's session
where do you go and learn more at this
point we're providing a lot of valuable
information for you to get started
number one where I have public facing
information
and templates and content that are open
source and available for you to readily
access download and to start to take
advantage of and get started today we
also have public information on our
website and most importantly we're
interested in learning more from you
about what's top of mind for you so feel
free to reach out to us at cortex
framework at google.com
that concludes today's session
chai and I want to thank you for your
time we look forward to working with you
and to engaging with you further on your
data Cloud journey and helping you
understand how our latest Innovations
and lean Frameworks such as cortex
framework can help you deliver value to
your business and get there faster
thank you again for your time
thank you